[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale a préparé par les équipes de tv
78 nous sommes le lundi 28 février voici
des titres il y a cinq jours la russie
déclaré la guerre à l'ukraine en
envahissant le pays comment les
yvelinois d'origine ukrainienne vive
kielce conflit à distance leurs
témoignages dans cette édition le salon
de l'agriculture a ouvert ses portes ce
week end à paris au programme spécialité
agricole démonstration encore concours
nous reviendrons sur celui du meilleur
berger de france auquel ont participé de
zibeline oise et puis demain le fc
versailles affrontera nice en demi
finale de coupe de france de football
coup d'envoi du match mardi à 21h
comment se prépare le club de nationale
2 nous avons suivi le dernier
entraînement dans les yvelines avant la
rencontre c'était à clairefontaine
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre cela fait
cinq jours maintenant que la russie a
déclaré la guerre à l'ukraine des forces
russes essaye de prendre d'assaut de
nombreuses grandes villes du pays dont
kiev la capitale vivre ce conflit à
distance c'est parfois compliqué pour
les yvelinois d'origine ukrainienne ils
nous racontent comment ils le ressentent
les témoignages recueillis par bixente
mais rien senti steban et célia gars de
son goût
natalia guaino et marina baranova son
mère et fille l'ukrainienne natalia a
vécu à kiev jusqu'à ses 30 ans elle
habite désormais dans les yvelines la
guerre en ukraine quasiment inconcevable
pour elle j'arrive toujours pas à y
croire en fait ben on les lit tension ça
dure déjà depuis des années mais c'est
vrai que la guerre comme ça avec des
bombes qui tombent sur 10 villes c'est
c'est incroyable franchement j'étais pas
prête même sentiment pour sa fille
marina parti à l'âge de 6 ans de kiev il
lui reste encore de la famille là-bas
qui change quand je suis pas fier d'un
mot qui a fait fort pour pour décrire ça
mais moi j'ai mon père qui est là en
fait qui est à kiev et du coup j'ai un
peu les infos en temps réel qui sont
encore plus horrible en fait que ce
qu'on entend ce convoi
à la télé donc ouais ben c'est ça en
fait qu'à la sirène qui retentit nuit
ils ont ils reçoivent un sms pour dire
qu'à chez vous et ils doivent s'abriter
le plus possible dans des sous sols des
parkings et enfin des endroits isolés où
ils risquent moins leurs vignes on
habitait là bas il ya quelques années
donc en soi on aurait pu être là bas en
fait je n'a pas déménagé on entrait dans
les bombes à concrètement très loin
physiquement du conflit les deux femmes
soutiennent à leur manière leur famille
et amis marina est parti plusieurs fois
manifesté j'ai su aller le jeudi le
public y avait une manifestation je suis
allé le samedi le dimanche
c'est de faire tout ce que je peux après
c'est pas énorme mais en fait d'ici on
sent vraiment impuissant par manifester
je partage beaucoup sur eux sur les
réseaux en cause ce qui se passe de ce
qui est des gens qui sont très étranges
et être un agent des liens de de soutien
à mes amis aussi kg l'aider
les deux humanitaires par exemple les
doigts réfugiés libre mais d'alarmé ou
pourraient l'être pro craignant ne veut
pas dire être contre la population russe
ici sur le territoire yvelinois il n'y a
pas de conflit entre les deux peuples et
j'ai plusieurs amis qui sont d'origine
russe est pareil qu'ils vont envoyer
plein de messages en disant qu' ils
comprennent pas on comprend pas comment
c'est possible il supporte l'ukraine
c'est très important nous nos peuples
étaient toujours très très proche donc
là que la culture ukrainienne et la
culture russes et les deux cultures qui
sont communes dans les yvelines
l'association us aux fans du chéné prône
justement les liens des deux pays et
même plus largement de la communauté
russophone sans émettre d'avis sur les
questions géopolitiques
nous avons semble que la risée
l'association dans son positionnement
à politique parce que c'est la meilleure
capacité de préserver l'avenir on est
que centré sur les dimensions
culturelles alors avec des activités
mais on fait des événements on fait
parfois des concerts séoul et des
spectacles de danse avec des troupes qui
viennent de certaines régions
russophones après les périodes de crise
il ya toujours des périodes de repos
construction et c'est la culture qu'il
faut préserver qui vous permettra de
reconstruire l'association laïque est
prête à se mobiliser en cas de demande
l'aide d'un de leurs 300 adhérents des
plates formes de soutien ont été mises
en place sur internet
un rassemblement pour la paix en ukraine
et est prévue dans les yvelines le parti
politique la france insoumise appelle à
se réunir ce mercredi 2 mars à 19 heures
le rendez vous est donné place sant
maclou à mantes la jolie et puis
toujours dans ce contexte le secours
populaire a lancé ce lundi 28 février un
appel aux dons urgence ukraine il est
disponible via le lien qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran l'association prévoit
également au plan départemental de
débloquer la somme de 5000 euros de son
fonds d'urgence et puis une aide de 50
mille euros sera débloquée sur le plan
national
et le conflit va aussi avoir des
conséquences économiques sur le monde
agricole au niveau de l'importation des
jets les prix flambent pour les engrais
notamment indispensables à l'agriculture
française et puis pour l'alimentation
comme les céréales aussi elle ça pose
des problèmes pour l'exportation aussi
puisque la france exporte quand même 780
millions de produits agro alimentaires
par an vers la russie est la chambre
d'agriculture d'ile-de-france jumelée
avec celle de lviv dans l'ue en ukraine
soutient les agriculteurs sur place les
précisions de christophe hillairet au
micro de nicolas landry regarder
[Musique]
la chambre d'agriculture est jumelée
depuis maintenant 6 ans 7 ans avec la
chambre de lviv en ukraine ville
austro-hongroise à l'origine c'est à
dire que est allé c'est une ville qui
est à 70 km à peu près de la frontière
polonaise
[Musique]
les gens sont complètement perdus même à
lviv qui est à 70 km de la frontière le
craignait ils ont pris un bombardement
en fait sur une base aérienne qui est à
40 km de la ville donc même à lviv en
tant que tels ils ont entendu les
déflagrations etc il ya un état
d'urgence qui a été décrétée c'est à
dire que les enfants n'ont plus d'école
et les salariés une peuvent dû aller au
travail ce qui pose d'ailleurs dans les
exploitations des soucis majeurs
puisque en fait vous avez bon nombre
d'exploitations qui ont des animaux et
donc les chefs d'exploitation sont
obligés de faire le tour des salariés
pour leur demander quand même de venir
au travail pour pouvoir nourrir les
animaux
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le premier objectif je pense
qu'il est humain avant tout c'est à dire
c'est de mettre les gens à l'abri en
fait de ce qu'il peut se passer là-bas
personnellement je vais accueillir
probablement des amis ukrainiens chez
moi donc on est en train de voir pour
les faire sortir d'ukraine actuellement
et j'ai pris contact hier avec le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines pour voir dans quelle mesure
vous pouvez accueillir
quelques femmes et enfants de deux du
secteur de lviv sachant que les hommes
souhaitent rester sur place pour se
battre un mois mon homologue qui est
président de la chambre d'agriculture de
lviv qu'à 62 ans vit soin de se battre à
62 ans il souhaite rendre les armes en
fait pour défendre son pays
[Musique]
et lors de l'ouverture du salon de
l'agriculture emmanuel macron avait
annoncé avec un plan de résilience était
en préparation pour soutenir le monde
agricole dans ce contexte
[Musique]
est justement le salon de l'agriculture
a ouvert ses portes ce week end il se
tient jusqu'au 6 mars lorien conseil et
manon batista vous êtes avec nous
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes toutes les
deux yvelinoise élèves à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet vous avez à
vous présenter ce week end
représenter l'île de france notamment
lors de la finale nationale du meilleur
jeune berger finale de la 17ème édition
qui a lieu ce samedi donc 27 février 26
février retour avec vous sur le concours
on vous avait rencontré en amont un déjà
lors de votre préparation vous étiez un
petit peu stressé comment ça s'est passé
sur place
jourdan de stress non on était très
heureuse de participer
après on s'est donné à fond et
ça a été une super journée riche en
émotions et
et qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté
justement ce concours
on a eu beaucoup de contact avec un
professionnel qui même les voir la
manière neutre des élèves qui ont
compris notre âge ça a été très
enrichissant vous avez pu voilà vous
faire un petit peu un réseau aussi avec
tous ces professionnels qui étaient là
finalement avec vous
vous avez donc vous avez déjà participé
vous manon à ce concours qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé cette année et
comment était l'ambiance sur place aussi
maintenant sur place cette année à
l'autre du but vide ça a été
une sacrée ambiance avec beaucoup de
personnes en public c'était plutôt
agréable
mais ça veut dire aussi beaucoup de
stress et puis j'ai jamais été aux
finales nationales c'était la première
fois et c'est vrai que c'est très
important d'être son grand rival c'est
quelque chose moi et donc les épreuves
là les alliés théorie et pratique est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire concrètement
sur quoi vous avez été jugée et comment
était le niveau cette année
donc ont été jugées sur leur
type de l'expérience - sur place dont on
est le triomphe du parage on a eu de la
santé oms a eu des deux
on a eu beaucoup de manipulations à
traiter après le niveau avec les autres
étaient très élevées aussi on est quand
même dans les 40 finalistes on prend ce
qu'on appelle ça veut dire les quarante
ans il ya donc c'était personnel est sur
place il fallait assurer aussi et
ça s'est très bien passé
et donc ce concours c'était aussi une
façon pour la punir finalement de
préparer la relève vous avez dû montrer
on vient d'en parler à vos savoir-faire
est ce que le fait d'avoir pris part à
cette expérience à vous conforte dans
l'idée de conserver ce métier finalement
de poursuivre dans cette voie
alors comment qui veux m'installer en
dix mois
c'était vraiment
le
but de
voir si c'était bien là tout ce qui les
ngoua et la réponse est oui je peux
changer de vie leur mouvement après et
pour moi c'était une expérience parce
que plomber ce
professeur de zootechnie ça mais ça m'a
apporté l'expérience en plus et ça les
douars que le lien avec les animaux
c'est ce que je veux et je veux pouvoir
transmettre mon savoir moi ensuite est
ce ce concours donc c'était une bonne
expérience vous venez me le dire est-ce
que ce concours ça vous a donné envie
aussi de participer à d'autres types de
titres comme celui ci
alors pour nous oui on est dans la
classe de bts 2e année six élèves
repartir demain pour le trophée
international des établissements
agricoles pour présenter une vache
laitière donc des concours de ce type il
montrera et on en fera jusqu'à qu'on
puisse bien faire est là les manger si
on est sélectionnée pour les finales
nationales
mémoire et pouvant donc retenter le
concours on l'a bien noté entre quand
vous souhaite bonne chance pour demain
du coup et merci beaucoup à tout les
deux d'avoir été avec nous un jeu
rappelle manon batista et lauriane
conseil en vous êtes élève en bts
production animale à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet merci beaucoup
[Musique]
et puis je vous le disais en titre
demain le fc versailles affrontera nice
en demi finale de coupe de france de
football les petits poucet de versailles
ont eu l'opportunité est de préparer
cette rencontre à clairefontaine au
centre national du football des
conditions professionnelles qui
ravissent les joueurs et supporters ils
sont venus en grand nombre finalement
pour assister dimanche 26 février à leur
dernier entraînement dans les yvelines
avant la rencontre face à nice donc
demain et céline charles s'est rendu sur
place regarder à deux jours de la demi
finale nice versailles de la coupe de
france les petits poucets yvelinois ont
pu se préparer comme les plus grands du
football français au centre technique
national de clairefontaine marquantes
annaba clairefontaine c'est le repère de
l'équipe de france ait essayé quand on
est petit on voyait envoyer nos stars
ici et là le fait d'être là le fait
devant le château dans les chambres des
joueurs c'est la préparation elle est
parfaite regardez à la claire fontaine
me ou d'autres reportages ou même que
quand on sait que tous les joueurs de
l'équipe de france jeunes ou adultes se
regroupent ici et que nous on a la
chance de profiter de ces installations
c'est magnifique tambours mégaphone
écharpes et drapeaux aux couleurs de
l'équipe les supporters sont venus en
grand nombre pour le dernier
entraînement en yvelines du fc
versailles elles ont battu une équipe de
ligue 2 qui tint s'est nourrie en ligue
1 c'est toulouse ils ont ils ont su se
battre et
aller jusque là je pense que contre nice
et peuvent continuer leur beau parcours
et on en reçoit tueur c'est bien pour le
club c'est bien pour la ville aussi
qu'on soit connue pour autre chose que
pour le château quoi donc sega c'est
bien pour les gens du club pour les
bénévoles pour les joueurs pour le stage
à temps plein plaisir plein de bonheur
de pouvoir partager ça avec et c'est
pour ça aussi que qu'on joue au foot
pour partager des émotions comme ça
venir nous encourager comme ça pendant
toute la séance nous on sent que bruce
est très important et pour moi comme
j'ai dit ça nous donne de la force à me
donne envie de nous surpasser déjà pour
nous et pour eux encore plus après la
victoire en quart de finale contre
bergerac le 9 février dernier joueurs et
supporters espèrent bien d'accéder à la
grande finale au stade de france il
s'essaye à quelques pronostics
je dirais un partout et
et puis les penaltys ont passé puis au
bas en finale ça serait bon c'est une
belle histoire mais après on est gonflé
à bloc et
là on a tous hâte d'y être on a tous
hâte d'être sur un terrain et aux
données tout donner pour gagner ce match
est obligé d'y croire sinon il n'y aura
pas qui veut y croire pour nous on part
on ne part pas favori mais on a notre
rôle à jouer dans ce match et on va tout
faire pour remporter ce match on mérite
ce qui nous arrive
une centaine de supporters fera le
déplacement à nice mardi pour la demi
finale
pour les autres ils seront devant leur
télévision ou dans les bars et cafés du
centre-ville de versailles qui prévoit
de diffuser le match
et à l'occasion de nice versailles tv 78
se mobilise on en parle avec vous
grégory canal et bonsoir vous êtes du
coup le rédacteur adjoint chef adjoint
pardon de télé 78 dispositif
exceptionnel pour l'occasion il ya
événement exceptionnel justin dispositif
exceptionnel nous serons en direct
demain mardi de 19h à 21h pour
accompagner les yvelinois jusqu'au coup
d'envoi de cette demi finale une soirée
mais deux émissions de 19h à 20h d'abord
l'édition spéciale de tv 78 nous livrons
les dernières heures avant le choc
reportages invités nos journalistes
seront également en duplex depuis
plusieurs endroits de versailles on
parlera aussi de ce moment historique
pour le sport vers ce versaillais ce
sera l'occasion est de mettre en lumière
d'autres clubs d'autres disciplines de
la cité royale et enfin on vous donnera
également quelques idées pour passer une
bonne soirée en famille ou entre amis
devant le match on a organisé justement
un duel un peu original pizza contre
kebab qui l'emportera pour être votre
repas du soir je vous laisse trancher
car on a la chance d'avoir à versailles
justin de très bons restaurateurs en la
matière parmi les meilleurs de france et
d'ailleurs et de 20 heures à 21 heures
on aura aussi une émission si on parlait
sport spécial absolument si on parlait
sport c'est notre émission tall que
toutes les deux semaines le mercredi sur
tv 78 au menu des as chroniqueur haut en
couleurs des débats animés des prises de
position sur le sport et les athlètes
yvelinois et bien la bande va se réunir
exceptionnellement le mardi soir c'est
toujours autour est de michael ennemis
devront comme entrer ensemble les
dernières informations sur le match les
compositions des équipes notamment
reviendra sur l'épopée magistrat du fc
versailles dans cette coupe de france et
on sait serra aussi à quelques
pronostics je vous avoue justin que je
suis très peu expérimentale la matière
en général je me trompe sur sur les
pronostics mais bonjour à dieu pour être
derrière les versaillais on va tenter
c'est noté merci beaucoup grégory canal
et je râle père vous êtes rédacteur en
chef adjoint de tv 78 soirée spéciale
donc nice versailles de 19h à 21h ce
mardi c'est à suivre en direct sur tv 78
notre site internet notre application
mobile et bien sûr nos réseaux sociaux
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant retrouvez votre magazine sportif
très bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]